depuis le début de la semaine la
transnistrie région séparatiste pro
russe de moldavie fait état d'explosions
sur son sol ce matin encore les
autorités locales affirment que des tirs
en provenance d'ukraine ont visé dans la
nuit un dépôt de munitions le ministère
de l'intérieur de transnistrie annonce
aussi avoir repéré des drones lancées
depuis le territoire ukrainien en parler
avec vous armelle charrier bonjour
doit-on craindre que ce conflit prennent
une nouvelle dimension qu'il dépasse les
frontières craignait oui on peut tout à
fait le craindre parce que la
transnistrie est un peu à la moldavie ce
que le dombass et à l'ukraine sauf que
la transnistrie en quelque sorte et à
une statue à part depuis 1991 donc on
n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes délais
c'est une langue de terre qui vit en
quelque sorte au rythme un peu des
mafias c'est toujours ce qui se passe
quand on est dans des endroits
séparatistes ils sont pas reconnues par
la communauté internationale et donc ils
permettent un trafic en tout genre
trafic d'êtres humains trafic d'armes
trafic de drogue les mafias russes ils
sont aussi impliqués donc les russes
connaissent parfaitement cette zone là
ensuite est ce qu'il ya vraiment
nécessité pour vladimir poutine alors
qu'il est en train de mener une guerre
aujourd'hui dans le donbass de faire une
guerre en même temps en moldavie
raisonnablement non militairement non il
est occupé d'un côté on voit mal ne pas
s'être occupé de l'autre en revanche ce
qu'on peut pas savoir c'est quelles vont
être les éléments déclencheurs les
éléments déclencheurs ça peut soit
échappé à vladimir poutine c'est à dire
que vous pouvez avoir des pro russe qui
sont dans la région et puis qui
s'agitent parce que dans ce cas là ils
veulent attirer l'attention des russes
ils veulent avoir quelque chose qui
dégénère vous pouvez aussi avoir des
gens qui sont du côté de la moldavie pro
européen pro et qui veulent aujourd'hui
récupérer la transnistrie donc ils vont
se faire passer pour des russes pour
dire où des pro russe pour dire on agite
effectivement le drapeau rouge etc ça en
fait qui inquiète c'est la présidence
moldave qui a essayé de calmer le jeu
qui est une femme qui est elle pour
l'europe mais qui sait quand même dans
quelle dimension on irait si on devait
aller vers la est donc dans ces cas là
ce serait effectivement c'est grave par
ailleurs gazprom interrompt ses
livraisons à la bulgarie et à la pologne
car ces deux pays de l'union européenne
ont refusé deux pays l'heure de payer
leurs factures en roubles c'était une
exigence de moscou en leur coupant le
gaz vladimir poutine il adresse là un
message politique à ces pays qui ont
rejoint l'union européenne oui politique
dans le sens qu il a choisi deux pays
qui sont bien ciblés les deux ont fait
partie de l'union soviétique les deux
ont choisi de regagner l'union
européenne et l'otan il chose se passe
bien donc je n'ai pas de problème
simplement quand on leur donne
effectivement cet impact cela ça veut
dire d'abord qu'ils ont des conséquences
économiques la pologne va davantage s'en
sortir mais la bulgarie va y être
beaucoup plus fragilisés parce qu'elle
dépend beaucoup de gaz et que par
exemple en bulgarie vous voyez que
l'opinion est divisée il ya une partie
de l'opinion qui est pro-russe et qui du
coup a plutôt envie d'écouter le kremlin
a plutôt un ancien regret de cet empire
soviétique
et puis vous avez une autre partie qui
est passé complètement autre chose qui
adore la modernité qui considèrent
qu'elle est très heureuse dans l'union
européenne et qui est complètement d
accord alors ces sensibilités
différentes déjà quand on discute avec
des piles car il nous explique c'est
compliqué de raconter la guerre en
ukraine quand il faut faire des articles
quand il faut l'enseigner quand il faut
l'expliquer vous imaginez si en plus
vous avez des problèmes à la maison si
en plus quand vous devez chauffer alors
on est au printemps heureusement tout va
mieux mais si ça vient plus en hiver ou
quand vous devez cuisine et vous avez
des problèmes parce que vous n'avez pas
le gaz ça exaspère effectivement les
tensions donc ça c'est un point qui est
effectivement important sachant qu'en
plus la bulgarie a une cote dans la mer
noire qui a toujours était aimé des
riches russes qui venaient y faire leurs
vacances d'été qui venaient y acheter
des maisons et que là avec les sanctions
prises par l'union européenne déjà ils
ont commencé à s'en aller merci beaucoup
armelle charrier pour cet éclairage et
puis